welcome back everyone so i'm really excited to
continue this lecture series on reinforcement
learning and in this one i'm going to zoom
in specifically on deep rl deep reinforcement
learning or set another way reinforcement learning
using deep neural networks okay this is one of the
most exciting trends uh both in control theory
and in machine learning over the past decade
uh and there's just a ton of new and exciting
results out every month uh it seems on deep
reinforcement learning just a reminder this
is um following roughly a new chapter in the
second edition of our data driven science and
engineering book so i wrote a reinforcement
learning chapter to cap off that control theory
part it was also a great excuse for me to learn
more about reinforcement learning so that's
something actually just a meta point for for
all of you uh you know trying to explain things to
people is always the best way to learn something
and this was really you know i took this as an
excuse to i wanted to learn about reinforcement
learning so i wrote a book chapter and made this
this video sequence um so i hope you are also
enjoying it as much as i am okay so this is such a
big field i am going to touch on the you know the
tip of the iceberg of all of the different
techniques of deep reinforcement learning
and i actually have another video from you know a
number of months ago maybe even a year ago where i
talked at a very high level about how you can use
deep neural networks and reinforcement learning
and i mostly did this with examples and
demonstrations of all the cool stuff you can do
so today i'm going to dig deeper into
more of the algorithms and how these
different flavors of deep reinforcement
learning fit into kind of our classic
our classic pictures that we've been
developing over the last few lectures
okay i'm going to jump right in and hopefully
this one's kind of exciting all right so the first
type of of kind of deep neural network uh embedded
into a reinforcement learner kind of the simplest
thing you can do is what's called a deep policy
network so your policy function pi is presumably
a relatively complex function of the state uh the
state you find yourself in s and the action you're
going to take a so it's the probability of taking
an action given that you're currently in state a
and this is supposed to be optimized to
maximize uh future rewards in your system okay
so this policy pie could be pretty complicated it
could have there could be a lot of rules or you
know physics of how you make decisions and actions
optimally given the state that you find yourself
in i don't know why i have a terminator here but
presumably it's using a deep neural network uh
to optimize its policy and so that policy function
pi can be parametrized as a neural network with uh
weights theta so the input of the neural network
is the state the output is some probability of
which action to take and you may you know flip a
coin and take an action based on that probability
and so what we would be trying to do is to
optimize uh over these parameters theta to
maximize the future reward to give myself the best
policy pi possible okay so there is a brilliant
blog by andre carpathy deep reinforcement
learning pong from pixels where they essentially
walk through and they actually provide a
python code with about 150 lines of code
that actually codes up this deep policy
network so it's really really cool
basically how you would take a high dimensional
state s this is a high dimensional measurement of
your system this is pixel space so you know there
are over a thousand pixels in this image that are
input into this policy network and
then essentially the policy network
is optimized to make the best decision of whether
or not i should move up or down my my pong paddle
okay so you're this character on the right and all
that you have to do is based on the current pixels
decide what's the probability of moving up or down
and then take an action based on that probability
and so the idea here is at a very very high
level is that we have our policy parametrized
by the network weights theta and we're going to
optimize over theta to give us the best chance of
getting a future reward and i'm being a
little bit intentionally vague about you know
i'm not writing down a loss function a neural
network loss function that we're training over
because there are different ways that you
can optimize using these deep policy networks
and actually one of the uh the easiest ways
essentially you can use back propagation so
you know neural network training in general
uses this this idea of back propagation so
information kind of upstream can be propagated
back and eventually used to compute gradients and
optimize these these weights and so the basic idea
is that i would optimize my weights by computing
gradients based on this cumulative expected future
reward and so this is partly why i'm being vague
is you have a lot of choices on how to represent
this future reward so if you represent that that
cumulative future reward using a value network
so if you have a policy network to make actions
to take decision to make decisions on what
actions to take and you are estimating your
future reward using a value network that would be
an actor critic network so there's different ways
of kind of embedding information into this this
deep policy network but the basic idea is that you
you represent your policy as a network and you
optimize over its parameters using essentially
gradients through gradients of something through
back propagation i'm going to talk more about this
okay um this is an aside that i think
is really important and i want to tell
you about but if you don't love you know math
derivations you can skip these next five minutes
this is kind of the guts of how policy gradient
optimization works in general this is this is
more general than neural networks if you have a
policy function pi that is parametrized by some
parameters theta this could be a support vector
machine this could be some other kind of model
or it could be a neural network where
the weights are parametrized by theta
then i am essentially going to derive how if you
take the chain rule or if you take the gradient
of this this reward function this cumulative
reward function you can get a signal to update
your policy weights data so again if you don't
love math you can skip this next five minutes
but i think this is kind of important okay so
the cumulative future reward r sigma given a set
of parameters theta for my policy so you can
think of theta as being a policy if you like
is the following so mu sub theta is the uh kind
of expected future distribution or probability
of finding yourself in a state s at long
times given this policy theta so it's kind
of the asymptotic distribution if you played this
game for a long time this would be the expected
probability of finding yourself in
any of those states s out of all
possible states so this is a probability
distribution of where you find yourself
in long times this is kind of just to be
mathematically precise we need this part here
and we would add so uh so we wait by the the
probability of finding yourself in a state
in long time and then you weight by the quality
function the quality of being in that state okay
and and taking that action times the probability
of taking that action given your weights theta
this is a bit of a complicated expression this
is you can kind of convince yourself that this
is true and this is outlined in detail in the
chapter in the book that this is consistent with
how we normally write this reward function
as the sum of all the future possible rewards
this is just folding it up using this quality
function okay so it's the quality of being in
a state and an action so i have to add up over
all of the probabilities of being in taking any
of those actions so you can this is a sum or a
weighted sum over actions and similarly i have
to do that same weighted sum over states and i'm
using the asymptotic probability of being in that
state so this is the the cumulative future
reward and what you'll notice is that we now
we don't have the policy anywhere we just sorry we
do have the policy but it's parameterized by theta
so essentially what we can do is take uh the
gradient of this reward with respect to theta
because that's the signal we're going to use
to change or to update theta we're going to
use gradient optimization presumably using back
propagation in neural networks so we need to
compute this this gradient we want to move in
the direction that in theta that increases r we
want to move in the direction of theta that
increases the total reward and so if i take
the the chain rule here or just basically
propagate this this derivative through
you'll notice that this term here is a
function of theta and so i compute its its
gradient with respect to theta and the next
step is really just uh keeping track of
of algebra here so what i've done is i've taken
this expression here and i divide by the policy
theta and so i multiply by the policy pi theta on
the left so these cancel each other out i'm just
you know dividing by it over here multiplying
it by it over here so nothing changed now i'm
asking myself this question and i hope you're
asking the same question why didn't my mu sub
theta why didn't i have to chain rule this this
object here and that's a really good question
i'm going to have to think about that and
maybe you can comment below in the in the
video and we can work through uh kind of what
went wrong here but this is this is just a sketch
of how we can get uh this policy gradient
information okay so so you do this
and now you'll notice uh that this term here is
just the gradient of the logarithm of my policy
the gradient of the logarithm so now we
have pi my policy times the q function
so everything to the left here is
the reward is the reward that i had
times the gradient of the log of the policy with
respect to theta and so now this is the expected
value of my quality function times the gradient
of the log of my policy with respect to theta
and so this can be used essentially as the the
signal this i can compute uh so so essentially
i can compute the log of my my uh probability
pi and i can weight it by my quality function
and that gives me the information i need to update
my my weights theta so i just need to compute this
using back propagation and this is better
conditioned to compute with okay again this
is a bit of a mathematical aside but uh if
you're interested for example you know in how
you actually compute this uh this policy gradient
this is at least one way that you would do that
okay good so this is where i really wanted to
get to is deep cue learning so most of the most
impressive demonstrations of deep reinforcement
learning at least in the last five or ten years
many of them have been deep q learning where
essentially you learn a quality function with
a neural network so again we know this is the
basic formula for q learning it is a off policy
temporal difference learning algorithm
so this is my estimated i'm sorry this
is my estimate of my future reward if i'm
at state s now and i take action a now
and this is my actual reward if i take that action
and i actually get a reward this is the actual
future reward and so the error signal between
these i can use to update my quality function
as i learn through trial and error so
we've already had a whole lecture on this
So essentially what you can do, is you can
parametrize this quality function by some neuralnetwork weights
*theta* and this is really really
useful because if you think about the kinds of
things we use Q learning for, or deep Q learning
for, the state space *s* might be astronomically big
for example if I'm playing a game of Backgammon
or Chess or Go the number of board combinations
in chess is more than 10^80. It's
more than there are nucleons in the
known universe. And Go has an even larger statespace *s*
So instead of iterating over
states, over and over, what I'm going to do is
i'm going to parametrize this quality function
by a much lower dimensional set of parameters
*theta* and then optimize over *theta*
So essentially you can think of this as extracting low dimensional features of your qualityfunction
that are parametrized by *theta* or
you know some neural network... and we're going
to optimize *theta* to get a better Q function and
this is going to really be important to
address the curse of dimensionality we have
in these very high dimensional state spaces.
So with this one, I actually will write down
the actual cost function involved in solving
this... so this is the neural network cost
function that we use when we build a
deep Q learner. Essentially the loss function
that the the network is trying to minimize
is the expectation of the square of this temporal
difference error... so this is literally just
the temporal difference signal here where
now my Q functions are parametrized by *theta*
and so the neural network is going to use its algorithm,
stochastic gradientdescent
and back propagation to optimize these
parameters *theta* to give me the best possible Q
function that minimizes this TD
error, this temporal difference error.
And again, we think that there is a strong
evidence that's what biological learners
are doing... at least at some level of
their neurological hardware
is minimizing this temporal difference
error that we talked about in the last lecture.
So this is pretty cool... you can actually just
take the update, turn this into a loss function
and the neural network is going to optimize those
parameters *theta* for you
and that's been a very very powerful approach so you know we've seen
this in the deepmind atari video game playing so
this is one of my favorite examples of block out
you've seen this before if you watch my channel
where essentially from this pixel space a deep q
learner with a convolutional level layer can learn
the right strategy the right quality
function for what actions to take
uh given given what state it finds itself in and
it actually learns some pretty interesting things
that it should actually eventually drill a hole
in one side here and then it'll basically work
itself out and that's the most efficient way to
increase its reward which is really cool that's
that's why they say human level control
because this this algorithm this deep q
learner is exploiting the physics of the game to
get solutions that only expert humans would find
and so this is the architecture so it has some
convolutional layers some fully connected layers
you know from pixel space to joystick you
know signal but essentially this is just
a big uh kind of deep q learning
demonstration convolutional cue learning
and this is just the list of all of the video
games and i guess you know the ones above the
line it is better at or better than human level
and the ones below the line it's still not as good
okay so that was deep cue learning essentially
you can have this this traditional q learning and
you can cook up a loss function for your neural
network that will essentially through trial and
error through experience it will learn the weights
theta that give you the best q function possible
and there's a variation of this that i really like
called deep dueling q networks or dueling deep q
networks ddqn which essentially takes your quality
function and it actually splits it into two
networks a value network which is just a function
of the current state and an advantage network
which says what is the advantage over just the
value of being in that state for taking an action
a so this is a good architecture when you're the
difference in in quality for different actions is
very subtle so maybe i'm in a really good board
position in a game of chess and the different
actions i take are giving me very marginal
increases or decreases of my quality function
and so what it does is it splits off the
value function of just being in a state
from the incremental advantage of taking an
action having been in that state and i mean
this is essentially equivalent to the q function
it's just another way of writing the q function
but now you can train two neural networks
and they're kind of dueling with each other
the value function is trying to get as much
explanation of that q function just from the state
and this advantage network a is trying
to figure out what the effect of taking
actions is and then you can kind of optimize
over these actions and do interesting things
okay another really really important concept in
machine learning sorry reinforcement learning is
the actor critic learning and actor critic
methods are actually way older than deep
reinforcement learning so i'm going to tell
you what they are in general and then i'll
tell you how we use them for neural networks
so the idea of an actor critic reinforcement
learner is essentially to take the best of both
worlds from policy-based and value-based learning
so in the you know a few lectures ago we talked
about policy iteration and value iteration
and they have these kind of different
flavors and different benefits and strengths
and so in an actor critic framework we're
going to have two um two learning two learners
an actor and a critic and the actor is
basically trying to learn a good policy
and the critic is critiquing that policy based
on its estimate of the value so the critic is
learning a value function essentially and the
actor is learning a policy uh okay good so the
actor is trying to represent this policy pi and
the the critic is going to be uh using information
from its estimate of the value function and
so one really really simple way to do this is
remember that policy gradient algorithm i was
telling you about you can essentially do an
actor critic policy gradient where what you do
is you're updating the parameters of your policy
uh so this is policy update data but you're using
the temporal difference signal from your value
learner so your value function is getting updated
too you're trying to learn this value function
from your critic and your critic is essentially
giving you the error signal that you use to update
your policy so again this kind of mixes the best
of both worlds you're using value information but
you're using that to update a policy using this
kind of in some cases gradient policy information
now in the context of deep neural networks
there's some interesting things you can do
one of the ones i like is called this advantage
actor critic network and it uses that uh
deep dueling queue network i told you before
where you split the quality function into the
value function plus the advantage of taking an
action and so essentially now the actor again is
a deep policy network so this is a deep neural
network for the policy with some weights theta
and then the critic is a deep dueling q network
uh q that tells you what's the quality of being
in a state and taking an action and so here
similarly this is that policy uh iteration that
policy gradient iteration i wrote down earlier we
derived earlier except now this policy gradient
is updating the deep policy network and and
gradient iteration is much much faster than
the model free techniques i was telling you about
in the last lecture using gradient information
will converge way faster than traditional
q learning or traditional value iteration
but it requires you have a model that's
parameterized by theta that you can take
the derivative with respect to theta but remember
in that deep policy gradient we needed our quality
function and so this again this is an actor
critic network because i'm doing policy iteration
a policy gradient iteration in this case but i'm
using a q network for that quality function so
my q network is learning the quality function and
i'm updating my policy using this policy gradient
network and presumably you update your your ddqn
the way you always do by once you take actions
and you get rewards you'll update this this q
function using the temporal difference error
so i think this is really cool you can kind
of mix the best of a value-based formulation
and really q networks are kind of value-based and
policy-based you know for the optimization so you
optimize the policy using value-based information
so this is really cool and this is different than
q-learning which is purely value-based so in queue
learning you are still updating the q function
but you're updating the q function based on
q information and then at the end of each
optimization then you figure out what your best
policy is just by reading it off whereas here
you're kind of jointly you're optimizing the
policy directly but using this uh this cue
information this this value-based information so
this is kind of a neat a neat approach okay so
that again was just the tip of the iceberg of
deep reinforcement learning but we got a little
bit more specific into some of these methods so
very very popular deep quality function networks
you can use those to do deep policy gradients
for example in an actor critic so if you like
you know there is an actor critic method that
uses a deep q network for the critic to do a deep
policy gradient uh optimization now you'll notice
conspicuously here there is this deep model
predictive control block that i didn't really
talk at all about it's kind of a different uh
a different flavor of optimization and i'm almost
certainly going to have a whole video or series on
deep model predictive control later but there's
some really interesting work in the community
where people are learning these kind of really
good optimal nonlinear controllers using these
these classic dynamical systems
optimizations like model predictive control
but then they try to learn a policy that mimics
that that model predictive controller so this
can be a very expensive online optimization it
requires a lot of model forecasting it's very very
computationally intensive typically and so if i
do that expensive computation maybe i'm teaching
a quadrotor how to fly through an obstacle
field once i learn the right control actions
maybe i can embed that in a neural network
maybe i can train a policy that very rapidly
kind of encodes the information of these deep
model predictive controllers okay so that was
again just a very high level overview of some
really important topics building on some of
the pieces that we've been learning over
the last few lectures all right thank you